Do you know Carl Castle?
His and the others from National Public Radio can be found at npr.org/community.
Here's the NPR news program called All Things Considered.
You are reported by Robert Siegel and All Tech Considered is on the show.
Nowadays, you can practically learn everything from video on YouTube.
(First of all you put a tie around your neck ...)
A South Carolina man teaches you how to tie a tie.
His video has been viewed on YouTube more than 650,000 times.
Or maybe you always wanted to learn to play the piano.
(Now we'll make a minor chord. Middle finger ...)
Today we'll talk to All Tech Considered the man who dedicated his life
creating video tutorials on YouTube.
Sal: Welcome. The theme of this presentation is the multiplication of fractions. I think you'll be happy
because you will find that this is one of the cases when multiplying something is easier than adding.
Don't you believe? So let's look at it.
Robert: This is Salman Khan.
Not the famous Bollywood actor
but a former investment fund analyst, now an author of educational videos.
Has more than a thousand video tutorials on YouTube
from ordinary multiplication through fractions to polynomial approximations of functions.
And today we can welcome him to California, our studio in Silicon Valley. Welcome.
Sal: Thanks.
Robert: Your YouTube channel is called Khan Academy.
Why did you decide to become an online tutor?
Sal: It was quite natural. I started to remotely teach my relatives
in New Orleans.
Back then, as you said, I worked as an investment fund analyst in Boston.
My cousin Nadia had problems with the basics of algebra.
I suggested that I could teach her at a distance,
for example, via a conference call
or chat via Instant Messenger or something. Finally, we started using Yahoo Doodle.
Soon it was said among relatives and friends, so I had about ten, fifteen students.
And then it became difficult to organize, to reconcile my work and their football training,
moreover, I had to explain the same things again and again according to my students' age.
So I started recording lessons. They were as conceived as when I was teaching Nadia.
Subsequently, I uploaded videos to YouTube so that my or your great-grandchildren could learn from them.
Robert: I've seen a few videos, and I noticed you never saw them on them.
There's just a cursor that draws on a black background while you talk.
How do you do that?
Sal: I used MS Paint at the beginning,
I created a black background and then used bold colors.
I used a shareware program, I think it's called ScreenVideo Recorder. He was $ 20.
So I simultaneously recorded my desktop and my voice.
So the videos were made. It felt like
the fastest and cheapest way to create decent quality videos.
Then one viewer gave me the Camtasia recorder software to record a desktop for $ 300
and I'm currently using other shareware, I think it's called SmoothDraw2.
I have it on drawing and I use a small Wacom graphic tablet.
Robert: Let's see what areas your video tutorials cover.
Mathematics, Chemistry, Biology.
Sal: And in the area outside of science, it is mainly economics and finance.
A large number of materials were created last year during the financial crisis.
I transferred my investment fund funds to cash
and then I started reading the Federal Reserve System Act. I read it about 10 times
just to see what the federal reserve chairman can do,
and I said to myself: How can I best use the time I devoted to learning something?
What to create a series of videos about Partial Reserve Banking and the Federal Reserve?
I do not want to limit myself to mathematics and science alone.
Robert: There's one thing I noticed when I watched a video about stocks.
I think you said there that a share of $ 1 per share may not be cheaper than
share of $ 10 per share.
And at that moment, a Google ad message will appear on the screen
which sends me to a site with different penny stock stocks.
This is advertising, and it is based on the assumption
that you will follow the video content.
Who is the advertiser of these ads? How many of your courses include advertising
and what opinion do you have on such a combination of education and advertising?
Sal: This service is provided by YouTube and its effect is that it is on YouTube.
I'm getting some of the revenue.
It's about $ 1500 for Khan Academy Inc.
which is a non-profit organization.
So the money goes directly to the organization, definitely not part of my paycheck.
Robert: Considering your previous job, you think that without advertising
is this project self-sufficient? Is there a career to do?
Can it work when people have access to free videos?
Sal: Currently, the project is not self-sufficient.
I often joke that the project is funded by Mr. Salman Khan's account in Bank of America.
My wife gave me the ultimatum that she must earn the project on her within a year
but I think it will be more benevolent.
The project has no outside support besides financial donations from viewers.
That's about $ 1500 a month.
And then those ads on YouTube.
If the ad were more aggressive, I don't want to
I would probably make a few thousand dollars a month more.
As the number of viewers increases,
which is about 15-20% per month
I am relatively confident that within a year only this source of income should cover my salary.
Robert: Are you your boss and the only employee?
Sal: Yes at the moment.
About two months ago, volunteers suddenly appeared
to translate videos.
One of them is a chemistry teacher from Uruguay who created the first translation.
There is an effort to translate into Arabic, Polish, Portuguese, German.
But I've created all the content so far.
Robert: You act as a very natural teacher in the videos, so I think
Whether you are studying in a technician at Massachussets and trade at Harvard or then as an analyst
ever thought you would become a teacher?
Sal: I taught high to earn some money.
I worked as an MCAT instructor for a year at the University of Princeton
and I also taught second grade students at Devotion School in Brookline.
I enjoyed it, but the economy and the investment funds were a little bit more fun.
Robert: Could you create a video comparing the investment fund analyst's and the teacher's salary.
Real-time communication with students does not work in online learning.
Do you think this may be another plus in teaching? Does it play a role?
Sal: I think that's the advantage I have over traditional teachers
judging by my experience with traditional teaching. One of the hardest things to do is sit against a class of 20-30 pupils
of which five seem to perceive you. The rest are just staring at you
and you do not know if they are bored or they do not follow the interpretation. It makes you uneasy and you don't know what to do.
I will explain something to my computer in ten minutes, as if to explain it to you or your cousin,
and then upload it to YouTube. It takes about half an hour.
In the first hour of uploading a video, a hundred people watch the video, and I wait to see if five stars
and write to him "that's great" or "I can handle the tomorrow's test" or anything else.
I'm waiting for feedback from viewers. That will give me the courage to work on.
Robert: Salman Khan, lecturer in mathematics, science, economics and many other things at khanacademy.org.
Robert: Thanks for coming. Sal: Thanks for the invitation.